I'll explain the language for the non
chemistry people here does anyone know
what the half half of you tell you
achieve 38 is a mi 26 days really wow
you guys have a very inflated view of
radioactivity ok for 2238 right by the
way for chemistry people who can explain
collection I don't entirely understand
what why is there a number there what is
a 238 unify the mess so that means what
how many protons and neutrons together
yeah ok you could tell any of our
chemistry um are in the nucleus yeah at
least I know if that is okay and I can
pronounce it um this thing is
radioactive okay it was it became sort
of famous because there's a lot of
edible not love it relatively a lot of
it at the UM the power plant at
Fukushima that melted down okay so there
was some of this then this is the most
dangerous stuff I'll explain this in a
second because it has a half-life I'm
just eight years okay now before I give
you some comparisons right you need to
understand it's not a long time what is
halfway what is halfway okay ah an
excellent game is what it is no fool
firstly right you want to think about
this idea of decay right it's um some of
you only just got it we're really slow
this morning are we okay fine it's an
all day our puff life is the idea that
when you've got some radioactive pile of
material ok because it's radiating stuff
off ok it's radiating radiating our
energies ok but even really dumb non
chemistry people know their energy and
mass are interchangeable right sir being
that it's radiates energy it's actually
losing mass from in there ok so after
the passage of time it'll become smaller
still radiating out stuff right but it's
ready to get out less because it's
already lost all of this matter right
now half-life is a measure of how
quickly that happens the question is
given some initial amount right like a
kilo how long would it take to get to
500 grams
okay now the reason why it's called a
half life and not the one kilo 2 500
grams life is because it doesn't matter
how much you start with as long as you
get to half right so for instance I
could have just as easily have said one
time and 500 kilos the reason why is
because what we're looking at is always
proportional to mess so if there's more
of it it's shrinking down faster ok so
this half-life of plutonium 238 88 years
you're like 88 years that's forever I'll
be dead in 88 years of something like
that right just to give you a bit of
scale right um other kinds of plutonium
isotopes is that the freezer yeah other
isotopes of plutonium um there's what I
write down I did write down I'm 234 or
is it to 44 it's 244 okay it's not 88
years it's 80 million years okay so
that's sort of more what we're talking
about right it takes that amount of time
you know you don't just walk along yeah
and you like oh look there's a rock and
it's disappearing before my eyes okay
things take a long time to radiate away
okay and the reason why is because you
need a heck of a lot of energy to lose
any substantial amount of mass right bad
anyway I'm getting into exercise too
much there you go there's a situation
now hope I'm podium 238 is 88 years so
he's the question I'd like to post to
how long will it take how long will it
take if I did suppose I did start with a
killer okay how long will it take to get
from a kilo 2 100 grams okay don't want
tickets you get from one kilo under
stuff passage of time and then I only
have a hundred grams left how long I
will just do it to the arm let's just go
to the nearest me ok now this question
is kind of the opposite of this question
in that this held your hands I had a
puppy party and so on okay it really
really guided you through here hmm where
do we even begin I haven't even given
you any variables I'm just giving you
some words what should we start with
I want to form equation to form
equations I'll need some printing rules
why not because I don't know what any of
them are so let's introduce that what do
you think would be a good current in one
to choose we're talking about how heavy
this stuff is right so how about em for
mass then mb the mass of pertain to 38
okay how much do you want to start with
how much booty in 238 you want to start
with I know you could start with this
okay but let's form a general equation
first because this doesn't tell you
about you know I started with this much
and then end up with this much it just
says the half-life okay oh by the way
the arm traditional symbol for half-life
is the UH the Greek letter lambda okay I
only like saying that because it's a
cool letter now if lambda is 88 years
okay what equation can I form with this
hmm well normally would say what does a
decay situation look like it looks
something like this right so we're
expecting something of this form n
equals M naught e to the minus can't eat
ok now just off of here right I don't
know what M naught is am NOT could be
anything here's a specific example but I
can still form in equation that tells me
like from this what kind of equation are
you working with okay I should be able
to work out the value of K how quickly
or slowly this is happening how am I
going to do it why can I go where can I
go from here well if the half 588 years
right and i started with M naught in 88
years how much will I have half of em
not right remember and lots a number
it's not changing like em and what's a
thing that you start with okay so
therefore the mass will be half of em
not when the time
is 88 years look that's not too it's
okay there you go okay so you can see
you can form an equation here that
doesn't have any with a particular mass
and that's the whole point of half-life
right then it's irrespective of how much
you actually have okay right so i can
simplify this a little bit can i and get
a half over here divided by m naught and
then you get to this point and you'll
get to this point a lot won't you ok so
again i'm going to take logs of both
sides i'm going to swap the things
around just to save myself a bit of time
ok so now i have a value for K just like
before we have a negative at the front
that is not worth getting rid of ok even
though you might think Oh we'd be really
cool and nice and knit to call this one
on a log too because that's what it is
but this negative is going to cancel
with this one in a second okay so you
might as well just kind of let it stay
put so now I can put this back in and
say well therefore this is what M is
there you go so my negatives are
cancelled out but it is still decay
situation because that log half is
actually a negative number right now I
can put in my specific details here and
I'm running out a bit of them solve
stick in there I want to start with a
killer and I want to end with 100 grams
right so where do those numbers fit
which ones which I want to own what 100
grams and I start with a thousand grams
thought I ok so I've got 100 over here
and a thousand over there right and then
I have all of this stuff up in the index
ok so now just like before I'll divide I
get this I'll take logs of both sides to
get that tea out of power ok and now all
i need to do is divide to get t by
itself right so if i divide looks like
i'll get eighty eight of these over that
ok you get your calculator out make sure
you're careful with your brackets and
what do you get
now again does that make sense is not a
plausible value does it look like what
you expected sit in the ballpark beaming
you know idiot uses the half-life right
and you're trying to get to a hundred
grams a tenth of your size after 88
years you've got a half after another 88
years let's let's call that 90 because
it's easier to do numbers in our head
okay about 90 years you've got half
another 90 s 180 you'll have a quad up
another 90 years that's 270 years I'll
have an eighth an eighth is pretty close
to attend isn't it so we are over by
ballpark and you can put it back into to
make sure that it works with the
equation may go okay but as you can see
from about let's see from about this
point or possibly even earlier all
exponential growth and decay is is just
arithmetic not entirely even algebra
right I mean you've got the t floating
around but you just sort of push him
around when you need to okay all of the
tricky things are really in hearing your
setup I hope you've um you're getting in
the sense that often it's like that
these kinds of applications of calculus
okay